[Musique]
l'avez sans doute encore m
justin dior de l'informatique le warren
buffett la finance elon musk de
l'innovation ou le aliko dangote de
l'afrique
et pourtant il ya deux mots avec ma
courte carrière d'entrepreneur
j'ai entendu je les ai entendus plutôt
un nombre de fois incalculable
c'est l'humain et le malheureusement
laissez-moi vous citer quelques-unes de
cette phrase sidérante
tu es beau gentil
malheureusement il s'est engagé
votre dossier de candidature il est
parfait malheureusement vont désigner un
candidat est celui qu'ils ont tant
depuis ces trois dernières années en
tant qu'entrepreneur autre business plan
il est solide
c'est du béton il est bancable
malheureusement nous finançons pas ce
type de projet ses mots quand elle
s'immisce dans une phrase elle que le
désespoir et la peur la peur à porto
nous y un instant la mise hors contexte
culturel
il est difficile de sortir du cadre de
prendre des risques de découvrir
d'explorer l'inconnu
je me rappelle quand j'étais enfant j'ai
discuté un peu avec ma grand mère je lui
demandais y avoir ou qu'on dit de ne pas
faire ça et me répondait en douceur
bissongo c'est la tradition il faut
respecter la tradition
je n'ai rien contre les traditions je
suis parti à l'école avec mes
professeurs
je demandais souvent ces petits
messieurs excusez moi cette formule vous
permet d'expliquer plus en profondeur
j'aimerais bien me l'approprier on me
disait non laissez pas la peine applique
là et tu auras tes points après ma
carrière d'entrepreneur
lorsque j'ai présenté mon idée pour la
première fois je peux vous dire que les
feedbacks n'a pas été positif mais il
faut persévérer
l'entrepreneuriat à l'état nous y
instants aussi je vais vous raconter mon
histoire c'est elle qui m'a permis de
développer le projet la fibre et la
fibre et pâtissent simplement d'un
constat je venais juste de finir mes
études à l'université polytechnique de
bobo
j'étais comme tout bon étudiant devant
la cité assis et on attend avec quelques
dossiers déjà déposés dans quelques-uns
de structure de la place
et là on a vu des évasions de
vaccination passé je fais le génie des
systèmes industriels
je me suis dit qu'on ne peut pas
améliorer ce système est ce qu'il est
performant vous ajouter quelque chose
le rendre meilleur c'était l'idée du
siècle pour moi je suis parti j'ai vu
mon professeur j'ai dit monsieur j'ai
une idée qui va révolutionner le
transport et la conservation des vaccins
m'a dit christian c'est bien on peut pas
faire ça ici au burkina
et du coup j'ai cédé à la peur j'ai
abandonné le projet pendant trois mois
c'est lorsque j'ai vu un rapport de
l'unicef sur les enjeux des transports
du transport et de la conservation des
vaccins en afrique que je me suis dit ce
projet il vaut le coup d'être mises en
oeuvre
et là j'ai commencé à persévérer
j'ai parlé de mon projet c'est innovant
mais est ce que tu vas pas aller
travailler d'abord parce que ça la bonne
idée c'est très compliqué et on peut
même pas faire tout ici c'était le
premier feedback
heureusement je participe à une
compétition ici dans une grande dans un
grand institut qui est dieu et là je
peux dire que le jury n'a pas été top
j'ai eu les mains et le malheureusement
votre système il est bon mais
l'intégration des marcheurs à jamais
mais je peux vous dire il faut
persévérer
lorsque vous avez une idée il faut
convaincre que votre idée c'est la
meilleure nous avons eu le prix de
l'innovation pour intégré l'incubateur
le windsurf challenge est là la bataille
a commencé 2015
on est un 2017 2018 vont participer à
des grandes compétitions majeures sur le
continent toujours les mêmes les
malheureusement et il ya eu un heureux
événement c'était en encore passé lors
du branding africa forum où le projet
obtenu le prix de l'innovation est une
promesse de financement d'une structure
de la glace et c'est
le message que j'aimerais que chacun
garde au fond du lit
c'est la persévérance quelles que soient
les feedbacks négatif prenez la prenais
le peu de positif et essayé de mélanger
le tout les points négatifs peuvent être
des suggestions qui vous aideront à
améliorer votre produit
nous avons additionné l'un plein
d'innovations à l'intérêt de ce projet
mais innovation qu'est ce que c'est
inventé adapté créé nous avons essayé de
prendre le meilleur du marché
nous avons pris la mer isolation qui
existent système de régulation qui
permet aux agents de vaccination d'aller
sur le terrain et de ne pas transporter
des packs de glace et pour les
institutions qui se soucie de savoir si
leurs investissements touche vraiment la
cible
nous avons ajouté un système de
monitoring qui vous permet de savoir où
sont les portes aux vaccins et la
température à l'intérieur
innover c'est sortir des sentiers
sentiers battus parce que lorsque vous
devez fournir une solution il faut
trouver la meilleure qui s'adapte
vraiment aux besoins
on ne crée pas le besoin on répond au
besoin certains le clairon mais je vous
conseille de répondre à un besoin qui
existe et qui est pertinent innover
c'est aller c'est vrai dans un océan
inconnu parce que vous ne pouvez pas
demander à quelqu'un comment on fait ça
parce qu'il ne l'a jamais fait
je nous exhorte
tous à persévérer et à sortir du câble
merci
[Applaudissements]